but i just really just need to know
do you love me
no
no
no she didn't
i mean we already knew that was the case
but breaks your heart man
it is ximena calls mike weird and tells
him she's not in love with him
all this comes after he refuses to pay
for her plastic surgery that really hurt
when she said that we'll get into the
moments that led up to her honest
confession and you'll get a first look
at my exclusive interview with mike
where he reveals how much money he spent
on ximena that's like nine grand right
there and he gives us the backstory to
this chain and tank top look that has
become a meme i wore it because
she gave it to me for like good luck so
plus i thought you were 24.
ben catches mahogany and some alarming
lies the house
is in her house definitely no photos of
her anywhere
yet he's still trying to be her
boyfriend
mahogany am i your boyfriend or just
your friend this is crazy
let's talk about it hey 90 day fans fam
it's melicia
i know you come here for entertainment
and i want to give you all the
entertainment that i can but i would be
remiss if i did not mention our 90 day
fans fam in ukraine and russia because
of this show i've learned so much about
those two countries and to see what's
happening is heartbreaking but one of
the best ways we can help is by putting
love and positive energy out into the
world at this time
in any small or big way that we can one
of the ways i'm choosing to do it is by
bringing you some enjoyment with these
recaps by the way thank you for your
questions for mike i was able to get a
couple of them in you can check out the
full interview with him soon on et's
youtube channel or etonline.com
in the meantime let's get into ximena
showing her
that are nowhere near as beautiful as a
rainbow right now cindy
all right quick refresh ximena's been in
a little mood since mike arrived back in
columbia because she said she had to
reschedule her surgery
she had plans to get a breast
augmentation and tummy tuck that mike
refused to pay for
so she got money from a loan shark
which is illegal in most places and can
be very dangerous but clearly ximena had
no problem letting us know
all of that brings us to the top of this
episode where mike is taking ximena
wedding dress shopping
because let's not forget he proposed and
she said yes
on top of that like i said she got alone
so although she doesn't want mike around
[Music]
and she's treating him as if she doesn't
want him around she's still asking him
to pay for this surgery
princess
[Laughter]
aka she's not happy he won't pay for the
surgery
listen to what she told him once she
came out the dressing room
i want to tell you something if you were
going to pay for the dress but for my
operation you don't want to give me the
money
this doesn't make sense read between the
lines mike and accept it
it makes a lot of sense
but i like them the way they are you
don't need to have the surgery
oh sweet mike if only she cared ximena
went on to state her case on why he
should pay for the surgery
and she told him she needs the money
this week
is
ximena then tells mike no surgery means
no wedding dress with no wedding dress
there's no wedding let's get real ximena
is really manipulating this man into
paying for her surgery
and surgery is such a risky thing
personally
i wouldn't want any negative energy
around it in a circumstance like this
you want to make sure good is on your
side i asked mike if he ended up paying
for the surgery did you end up paying
for it mike i can't really say on that
you just have to keep watching and of
course he couldn't tell me
just like he couldn't tell me if they
are actually still together but he did
give me an estimate on how much he spent
on ximena since the beginning of their
relationship
and based on my calculations i think the
surgery might be included in his total
i would say rent is like five red and
food is like 500 a month for
um
so it's just about a year and a half now
so
that's like nine grand right there so i
would say like i would say like 15 or so
15 000
yeah like with the rent and everything
plus like odd things here and there mike
said he spent nine thousand dollars on
her then jump to fifteen thousand mind
you here's how much the surgery cost
not really for the surgery because
different complications can come up and
it also costs five thousand dollars
i'm not sure how much he paid for the
furniture and fridge he bought her but i
doubt if it was six thousand dollars
maybe one thousand and the rest is the
5k for the surgery
who knows we'll find out in due time but
i went to ximena's instagram and she
definitely wants us to see that she got
the work done
all right brace your hearts because this
next moment i'm about to show you
is tough
are you ready for bedtime
mike and ximena are getting ready for
bed and she tells him he needs to go
sleep in the other room he should have
told her this is my house
oh just kidding but mike of course is a
little shaken up by her request
he goes on to ask her if she plans on
getting intimate with him during this
trip and she straight up says no
no kiddo
[Music]
m
i was offended for mike but then she
started to explain why she called him
weird and
i'll just let you take a listen
to
[Music]
i'm not going to lie that sounds
exhausting oof
that's a lot
but before the surgery conversation it
seems as if she didn't mind saying
tiamote ammo every five seconds
but i see how that can get old and how
mike's clinginess can get annoying okay
um i won't be on top of you i'll give
you your space ximena then details this
uncomfortable moment she experienced
with mike
she woke up one morning and she says she
caught him awake just staring at her in
a strange way
which
is creepy
but i'm also not surprised mike can be
awkward which is fine
plus this is his first serious
girlfriend
but
he needs to stop doing that
ximena seems like somebody who does not
like to be stared at what are you
looking at no no i'm not i'm not spying
on you i just
like to
look at you because you're beautiful
when you sleep when you're up you're
beautiful all the time
mike responded by saying he will change
which is not the answer here but
ximena tells mike that she doesn't want
to get married yet but then she keeps
him hanging because she says she wants
to marry him just not now
this confuses mike so he flat out asked
do you love me i just really just need
to know
do you love me
estoy
[Music]
i do not love you
oh it's the shrug for me she said
i don't i don't love you i don't know
what else to say
these two are total opposites it seems
as if ximena doesn't know how to receive
love and mike is just so willing to give
it here is how he told me he felt in
that moment that really hurt when she
said that i kind of had friends tell me
about it because i didn't want to watch
that one again because i don't want to
relive it
so um
it's just that in that specific time
that one it was like it seemed like
everything i did was like
like
walking out like eggshells or whatever
sometimes we don't want to accept the
truth about a relationship because
accepting that truth can make us lose
the confidence we have and confidence
isn't always easy to get back but
obviously the way ximena's acting has
nothing to do with mike's worth this is
just how she operates a good thing about
mike though is that he knows how to
laugh at himself i brought up his tank
top and chain look that shocked us all
and turned into a meme here's what he
had to say about that it's a t-shirt
and the pajamas
and the chain is ximena got me on the
first trip
like
even though i am jewish so i shouldn't
be wearing it but i wore it because
she gave it to me for like good luck so
that's the reason why i had it context
is everything because i sure didn't
think he was over there trying to morph
into ximena's type
which i guess also isn't far from the
truth but
anyway
let's quickly touch on the bizarreness
of ben and mahogany storyline
it's just odd
everything about it is odd
last week we were shocked to find out
mahogany was real after many red flags
she never video called ben during the
three months they were talking she told
him not to come to peru and then she
ghosted him once he landed in her
country and then all of a sudden she
pops up this episode ben who was 52
asked to meet mahogany's parents with
hopes of convincing them that he's a
good guy and he loves their 24 year old
daughter which brings us to lie number
one
beautiful do you like that yes it's
gorgeous
ben arrives to mahogany's house and she
reveals that she does not live with her
parents
although she told him she did
in our texting she definitely told me
that she lived with her parents she then
gives him a tour of her place which as
you watch it becomes more and more
obvious that this girl does not live
here there are bunk beds why bunk beds
uh people can
get ourselves like friends like that
sure uh guest bedroom
lying is wrong and she has a bedroom
with nothing in it does this look like a
24 year old woman's bedroom to you
okay that was lie number two
and speaking of her age once her parents
arrive
lie number three is revealed
ben finds out she's not 24. well i'm
gonna
22
[Music]
you don't know my age
i thought you're 24.
oh my gosh yeah i am 100 positive that
she told me when i first met her she was
23
and when i was wishing her a happy 24th
birthday she never
denied there was definitely
more than a miscommunication on this one
because she never thought she was going
to meet you ben
she was out here having fun on the
internet after the age conversation ben
is totally thrown off and he decides
it's time for him to leave
the house
is in her house definitely no photos of
her anywhere
and
then i find out she's not 24. i don't
know it's only two years
but i've got a daughter who's 22. so
yeah this is weird this is really weird
weird is an understatement
i find it interesting that mahogany's
parents were in on the lie about that
being her apartment
my guess is that they didn't want ben to
know where they live
which i get
ben went to peru without ever video
chatting this girl
if he had her address
[Music]
lord only knows what he would do
based off what ben said including the
fact that his daughter is 22
you would think that after all of this
he's done with mahogany but
next week he's talking about being her
boyfriend
tell me
something about mahogany you want me to
know as her new boyfriend
mahogany am i your boyfriend or just
your friend
[Music]
i'm talking to ben soon so once again
let me know if you have any questions
drop them in the comments and i will
pick a few
and be nice try to at least try to be
nice okay
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you